hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to agario now I haven't
played it in a while and there's been a
lot of changes made to the game and
actually agario mods doesn't work
anymore so I can't exactly do that so
now I'm just gonna be playing on my own
and in a party I sent a tweet out to
everybody who wanted to join up on my
party and there may be some people that
are going to join ya I'm not entirely
sure but as it stands right now I'm just
gonna do my best
standing on my own with Kim Kardashian
following me from the behind and hello
mark over there
oh god no who is that oh I'm gonna get
boxed in oh they all think that they're
me but I'm not me they're not me I'm me
I'm the only me all people are given
themselves to the other mark EMU you're
a faker you're a clone faker you're not
the real me I'm the real me I'm the only
me here so I did tell people that I was
gonna be playing this but I didn't tell
them what my name was so it is kind of a
secret so they have to kinda guess and
if that mark EMU causes problems for
this mark EMU then I'm going to be very
upset and I'm going to be frankly not
happy with any of it it's going to be
boom and I'm going to be who and there's
going to be a lot of moons and moons all
over the place please feed the mark EMU
you got what do many oohs in your name
that's a bunch of baloney me sasa real
me I'm the real me me and only me is me
you can't be me I'm not a bean it's six
six six yeah it's wonderful wonderful
not a penis mark I feed you
I feed me oh there we go
man loves markiplier got a big start on
this one bean chica haha other mark EMU
who's the bigger one now you get sucked
into me yeah
oh no man he's getting away team chica
eat feed Makka Moo yes they're starting
to learn they're starting to learn who
their true Lord is their overlord
Marquis Moo oh no it's getting crazy
there's too many people
Oh God Oh God
I'm just gonna go back here into the the
birthing corners and then hope for the
best once I reassemble and then
everything's gonna be lovely notice me
Marc pi its I'm right here your senpai
is here Marc EMU is Bay everything so
scary okay
finally I'm reforming give me your power
give me all of your power this is the
best so many people mark my move I'm not
gonna mark your move that sounds like
dirty Oh something happened here okay
mark my move give me that ain't good
that ain't good I've reached level for
though they added a lot of like little
things like this so there's a lot of
there's a lot of microtransactions now
and that's unfortunate but you know I
guess they wanted to make more money and
I can't really fault them for that
so anyway oh wait no hang on I'm gonna
I'm gonna throw myself into jumbo I'm
gonna see Mark fist me I will not sir or
mayhem
either way the answer to still no the
real Marky mu Mark emo who the real
Marky Moe let's see if this works the
real Marky Moe is anyone gonna believe
me I think the answer is actually no cuz
whoa this server is getting nuts oh man
no I'm real
don't do it I'm the real one I'm the
real dark dark don't do it
Oh God no one's gonna believe me because
there's a misspelling in it Marky mode
they're like Mark emo that guy's stupid
there's no way
give me mass
I'm never gonna get sir because there's
so many people there Oh God oh the real
Marky Maho believe me believe me oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] skis ah [ __ ]
ah Danny sex bang [ __ ] Salomon ater I
can't believe I pronounced that right
I'm tiny tiny almost too big for these
things come on give the Marquis move
give the Marquis move you have the
Marquis move give Oh God
I'm too big for this no grammar nazi'
don't you dare grammar nazi' don't you
there okay I'm still small enough for
this boo-boos what booty sweat sorry I
thought it was booby sweat Marky we love
her come here come here come on it's me
trust me it's me it's the real me it's a
real me you didn't believe me oh god oh
god this bed slowing down lag lag lag
and I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm gonna get killed by bubble butt Tim
bubble butt Tim
bubble butt oh man
once more into the breach Oh cept apply
are away got eaten up just as it should
be
oh no oh no oh no fart apart I ain't
gonna do so good far deploy ain't gonna
succeed far the pleura ain't gonna make
it very far it's me it's for deployer
trust for the plier
you two breasts coming after me Oh sick
moves bro thanks me
give me your body septa flyer give it to
me give me your body no okay squeeze
between crescendo and Oh God this is
very scary oh man market dong of a fist
me mark again III say no to that I don't
I don't want to I really don't want to
oh oh oh man it's just a sandwich it's
just a sandwich
oh god it's just a sandwich what have
you done this no I will not fist you
stop asking me to I don't appreciate
these
haha - Big D [ __ ] you
oh no Target liar don't do it dr. Potter
no no I'm too beautiful to die we seem
to have escaped most of the people but
dark appliers chasing me down and it's
not cool whoa whoa whoa darker bar don't
want to mess with this now ha ha
who's the dark applier now oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh it's me Mary it's me it's me
give me Oh God that ain't good mini Boy
mark come on trust me it's the real me
it's the real me it is the real me it
has to be who else would it be
mark a new lover Marky moon lover can
you can you can you assist me mark emu
lover mini boy mark I don't want to do
this to you but I really really actually
do want to do this to you yeah there we
go now we're getting somewhere
oh we're just a bigger target we're just
a bigger target Oh God markiplier oh god
no no loopy don't do it no man I was
actually doing good there now I can't I
can't put out my name on the internet
because that people would just be like
oh I'm gonna type that name in and then
I'll be good I should be I should I
should get the Leprechaun just because
that'd be something identify a bullet
and it's something that not everyone but
do you'd be able to get but I don't have
enough coins oh but then I'd have to
spend money law alright no one do this
no one do what I'm about to do I'm doing
this for the sake of doing this and also
I should okay so I did something
incredibly stupid and I actually bought
coins don't do that everybody but now I
have I am a leprechaun aha can you see
my clever ruse
now no one will be suspect no one will
be able to withstand my Irish charms I
can't believe that this skin was
available no come on
trust me I'm me ass almost blasted me
halfway across the map dark apart
no God why try this again man that that
guy is big oh my god Inaki oh my god you
go to get over here
oh lordy doggy day a scrap don't get me
all Kitty derps holy audio t hot at all
is this how Irish talk what did Ollie
Dodie Dodie Lily Lily Lily Lily Oh God
there is no room anywhere here the big
ones are gonna get so big that they're
just gonna start popping no matter what
oh god kitty derps one out of that one
don't kill jack don't kill jack jack
your your Irishness is useless it's not
helping it's not helping at all it's not
helping nothing's helping the gargles
they do nothing the Irish whiskey it
does nothing there's so many people that
are pretending to be me they're getting
to the top of the leaderboard this is
[ __ ] this is a bunch of bull this is
not how this was supposed to go this was
supposed to be my moment of victory Oh
something big is happening over there
[ __ ] mark I know right what an
[ __ ] ruining the server and all chica
the dog you're gonna help me help Jack
help Jack not so grump get in my belly
yes I got someone it worth death oh [ __ ]
Dani good oh man oh god there's so many
big ones Oh God oh man the leaderboard
is changing every single second of every
single day
that is not what I would call good
there's the opposite of good little
biscuit dargah bar help Jack what are
you doing God they were all over me he's
gonna pay off eventually I'm gonna make
it to the top of the leaderboard okay is
my win I'm a bot [ __ ] I'm a bar [ __ ]
there's so many BOTS where are their
buckets why would anyone bought this
game oh god why come to the jack I'll do
that I'll take some of that
I'll get that action whoo this good are
these goons hottie scoot scoot scoot
yes yes come to me yeah you know you all
know what's going on all these new
players what God so many new players oh
man
yes yes go the other way now go on the
other way running away running away very
fastly oh hello
that ain't good could be good probably
ain't now we got it now we're going for
some don't know what but we're going for
something Oh God so scary no damn it I
was doing so good
Oh
Marky's and suck is a nice person I like
mark is a suck maybe he just didn't know
who the hell I was and just got
distracted by everything oh don't do it
oh god this is scary this is bad oh no
little biscuit I love my little biscuit
I love you
there we go that's my little biscuit
hunting for iris
you little biscuit don't consume me
though cuz I still don't trust you
oh man oh man it pays to be - whoa hello
okay then I'll just collect my do and
then get out of here a little bit get
well little biscuit little bit's get a
little bit o little biscuit you're the
best oh you're so good
careful little biscuit are you all right
oh okay you you did that thank you
boss lady oh thank you pepper oh you're
all so nice to me ah
I mean I'm gonna eventually betray you
and stab you all in the back but that's
besides the point
don't worry about it oh yes yes yes feed
me feed me hey you let off little boy
mark tiny boring mini boy mark mini boy
mark is my bud I'm not even on the
leaderboard and I've got 4,500 masks
this is this is bonkers
this is oh god why oh god how did this
happen how did this happen oh god what
happened anyway so mighty we'll go over
this a [ __ ] dude
this is Eve I can split split this [ __ ]
if I can just threads needle here not
even on up I just popped up on the list
man there are people that take this game
way too seriously
even with the combined effort of
everyone involved holy [ __ ] men that's
max he's number three and that size he's
number three oh my god I'm gonna give it
all the Boober Boober but give it all
the Boober never give it to member oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] everyone over there no one
won in that one okay so this was a gari
oh I had a ton of fun thank you
everybody so much for joining me but
when we flooded this server there's just
too many heroes we can't handle it all
but thank you everybody so much for
joining me if you want to
another game with me in the future and a
lot of you did play a game with me it
just didn't realize it but if you want
to play a game into me in the future
I'll tweet out another party at another
date in another time so thank you again
everybody check out the other agario
videos that I've done in the description
and as always I will see you in the next
video